[Music]
hi welcome back to Hannity We are
continuing to monitor the war in Israel
with Hamas here for a Hannity exclusive
interview her first since the terror
attacks this past weekend former
Secretary of State current director of
the Hoover institution and by the way
member of Augusta of which I'm very
jealous uh cond Lisa Rice is with us uh
Dr Rice great to have you I've not seen
you in a long time um I know you has
been a long time Sean Good To Be With
You great to have you uh as usual um you
know a lot about Terror you know I when
you extrapolate out I've been trying to
give perspective as to how big this
attack was over 1,200 dead Israelis as
of now and there probably will be more
by the time the count is is full and
complete and when you extrapolate that
out and you look at the the Israeli
population and you apply that same
percentage to the US population it'd be
the equivalent of losing over 37,000
Americans in a single day we lost
2,977 people on day you know well
91101 and I I the magnitude of that I
don't know if people understand it
around the world what does it mean to
you well the magnitude of it is
extraordinary and uh I've said to people
Sean yes uh there are the lives that
were lost in that way but it would be as
if uh the terrorists then went in into
small New York towns and slaughtered
people up close that they exterminated
people uh that they cut off the heads of
of babies uh this the scale of this
brutality and this barbarity is
something that we really haven't seen in
a very very long time and uh I think you
have to you have to look at both sides
of it the the loss of life is horrendous
but what the people of Israel are
feeling in terms of the shock of what
this was like uh I I just can't even
imagine it even after having been myself
the National Security adviser on
September 11th are you as shocked as I
am at the level of anti-Semitism that
we've seen both around the world on our
own college campuses and cities uh and
and towns across this country did you
ever think you'd see people in in
Australia uh saying gas the Jews F the
Jews uh or have you know tomorrow a day
of jihad uh all over the world which
should scare anybody uh in any City that
would be a Target um pretty frightening
times Madam Secretary it is and I'm very
I'm I'm I'm shocked by it and I'm sad by
it uh Sean because uh uh anti-Semitism
look is always just beneath the surface
in a lot of places I did a lot of work
with the uh the uh Anti-Defamation
League when I was uh secretary I spoke
at a couple of uh events that they had
and uh this kind of hatred uh is
something that I am afraid fre has been
a part of the fabric unfortunately of
civilized places for a long time and so
yes I'm saddened but I I also am hopeful
that uh there are voices that are
speaking uh strongly about the hate that
th this is that are speaking about and
condemning this terrorist attack and
that's that's what it was it's a brutal
terrorist attack of the kind that we
haven't seen since perhaps uh perhaps
Isis was uh roaming around the Middle
East and so yes it's it's said um I do
think it's an opportunity in places like
our own
universities uh to say to our students
take the time to understand uh this this
conflict in the Middle East understand
that Israelis have tried uh to help
Palestinians to a two-state solution and
a lot of decent Palestinians have tried
to and every time we've gotten close to
peace Hamas and Hezbollah and
Palestinian Islamic Jihad have uh done
something to dash the hopes of uh
innocent Palestinians and so uh they
they these are not the uh the liberators
of the Palestinian people these are the
oppressors of the Palestinian people and
these of course are uh The Barbarians
who attacked the Israelis what do you
make of the reports Wall Street Journal
and many other sources and even Hamas
and and Hezbollah leaders themselves
admitting that Iran's involvement in
this Iran is the number one state
sponsor of Terror um to me uh I think
they've got to be held accountable to me
that would mean military action in this
sense and I'm not saying necessarily
even by the United States uh taking out
their refineries because that is the
source of their income to fund Terror
and number two uh we know where these
nuclear facilities are and if there is
ever a marriage between the radical
mullers ideology and weapons of mass
destruction I believe they would use
them but these sites where we know are
located deep buried underground it would
be a very difficult military mission to
take them out but I think the world has
to at some point probably soon take them
out your
reaction well I would start by saying
that uh yes Iran a state sponsor of
terrorism uh Bears uh some
responsibility for what has happened I
know there are questions about how
directly were they involved but you know
we know that Iran is the major the the
primary funer of hezb of uh of Hamas and
Palestinian Islamic Jihad they are the
trainer of uh these groups um and of
course they were celebrating in Teran
when this happened uh the question of
what we do more broadly about Iran I
think is an important one uh for starts
uh let's not go back to the pretense
that we can have an agreement with the
Iranians about their nuclear facilities
uh let's not uh go back to the place
where we're releasing funding to the
Iranian mulas who then uh just use that
funding uh for Hezbollah and Hamas that
would be a good start and let's try
again to isolate the Iranians in the way
that we had earlier uh in uh the Bush
Administration and in the Trump
Administration uh the idea that you can
you can deal with the Iranians you might
find reasonable ways to deal with the
Iranians it seems to me that this is
just one one more example what we've
seen over this last uh few days uh that
the Iranians are a revisionist power
they are the most dangerous uh Power in
the region and oh by the way Sean uh we
gave up military facilities in
Afghanistan uh a country that uh has a
hundreds long kilometer border with Iran
uh that was a mistaken its own right and
so uh how to deal with uh Iran I think
it starts with isolating them I think it
starts with what actually the Biden
Administration is done I think sending
the carrier battle groups uh into the
region uh is a good idea but uh this
should really uh erase any notion that
the Iranian regime can be dealt with
former Secretary of State condalisa rice
has been way too long great to have you
back good to see you thank you for being
with us hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else